i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando nos hablan de trabajo en equipo
en que pensamos para mí son personas que
unirán sus fortalezas por un mismo
objetivo a alcanzar el éxito
si en definitiva para mí esto es trabajo
en equipo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
este es el equipo nacional de natación
artística atletas de diferentes estados
mujeres capaces de vivir y dejar todo
por un mismo sueño ser campeonas
imaginen la alberca de los juegos
panamericanos en guadalajara
se escuchaban cuatro mil voces entonando
el cielito lindo apoyando a sólo nueve
atletas de natación artística
esas voces se escuchaban para nosotras
como si fueran los 130 millones de
mexicanos que somos en este país
ahí se encontraban los máximos
exponentes de todo el continente
americano no queríamos ni podíamos
fallar
tocaba el turno de nuestra mejor rutina
nuestra carta fuerte una rutina que en
otras competencias nos había dado
grandes satisfacciones escalando lugares
dentro del ranking mundial ocular los
medallas internacionales una rutina que
habíamos entrenado durante meses y por
la cual habíamos dejado casa familia
amigos y la vida de cualquier joven a
sus 20 años nuestro momento había
llegado definamos hacia la alberca con
nervios de adrenalina
pero nuestra sonrisa reflejaba seguridad
y confianza
para ese momento varias de nosotras
éramos protagonistas en periódicos de
gran renombre
éramos jóvenes haciendo lo que nos
gustaba y además
nos pagaban por hacerlo
estábamos seguras que en esos juegos
panamericanos ganaríamos una medalla
porque éramos las favoritas porque
estábamos en casa y ante nuestra gente
la competencia siguió desarrollándose
hasta concluir la participación de todos
los países
en la pantalla central aparecían los
resultados finales méxico
cuarto el lugar
cuarto lugar
habíamos quedado rezagadas hasta la
cuarta posición por debajo de canadá
eeuu y brasil
fue muy doloroso darnos cuenta en ese
momento que de nada había servido a ser
las favoritas del evento o estar en
periódicos de gran renombre
pero sin duda fue aún más doloroso
darnos cuenta que en realidad no éramos
las mejores
creyendo nos las mejores nos cerramos la
única puerta que nos llevaría al éxito
el aprendizaje
en la vida se presentan cambios a cada
momento lo que hoy es en fracción de
segundos
deja de ser a veces es necesario que
algo se quiebre para que algo nuevo
pueda surgir
comprendimos que cada una tenía su
propia batalla interna
propia batalla interna regresamos a
nuestras bases si teníamos que empezar
de cero lo haríamos y sin miedo
comenzamos a entregar entrenar con esa
hambre que nos caracterizó desde un
principio
hambre hambre de ser hambre de querer
vivir mejor hambre de dejar a un lado
tanta negatividad y pesimismo dándole a
la prensa historias de éxito que valen
la pena contar dejando un lado egos y
protagonismo
muy lastimadas por aquel cuarto lugar
comenzamos a integrarnos cada vez más
iniciamos con algo tan básico
cómo hacer pequeñas reuniones donde
conocíamos nuestros miedos gustos y
debilidades
nos dimos cuenta
que cada una tenía esa batalla interna
cada una
verdad me que me distraje muchísimo nos
dimos cuenta que cada una tenía su
propia batalla interna que no era solo
lo que nos pasaba en el entrenamiento
sino también a lo que nos enfrentábamos
en la vida diaria escuela amigos y
relaciones amorosas que muchas veces no
compartían nuestros sueños
mi estilo de vida comprendimos que
aunque estábamos lejos de nuestras casas
y familias no estábamos solas y que
debíamos entendernos y apoyarnos entre
nosotras repasábamos una y otra y otra
vez nuestra actuación en guadalajara nos
rodeamos para analizar nuestros errores
y con humildad cada una aceptamos en que
habíamos fallado
nos dimos cuenta que nos volvíamos más
humanas al reconocerlo pero sobre todo
más conscientes sabiendo que si una
fallaba era responsabilidad de todas que
afectaba a todo un equipo
hoy les puedo compartir que agradezco
ese cuarto lugar porque gracias a ese
despertar pude lograr mis más grandes
sueños como atleta
recuerda una frase que marcó aquel
momento la frase decía lo siguiente
si un día llegarás a caer no te
preocupes
haz como el sol que cada tarde cae pero
cada mañana se levanta con más
resplandor
y nosotros comenzamos a brillar
fueron cuatro largos años de trabajo
duro de arduo entrenamiento de estar
alejadas de lo que más amamos que digo
cuatro en realidad fueron casi veinte
años de trabajo intenso
y vaya que si la vida da revanchas la
disciplina y el gran trabajo en equipo
comenzó a darle resultados país al que
llegábamos con que estábamos el podio
a tres años de la derrota en guadalajara
nos colgábamos en la medalla de bronce
en españa bola vamos hacia suiza y nos
cuidábamos la medalla de plata y en
budapest ganábamos el oro
recuerdo que para una entrevista el
comentarista opinó que habíamos tenido
mucha suerte
de momento no me pareció
pero hoy sé que la suerte es cuando se
reúnen la preparación con la oportunidad
se nos presentaba la oportunidad y la
aprovechamos porque estábamos preparadas
y que creen por fin llegaron los
siguientes juegos panamericanos evento
donde se disputarían las medallas que
cuatro años atrás habíamos perdido
pero ahora era diferente ahora no nos
sentíamos las favoritas ahora no nos
sentíamos las mejores ni había estrellas
ahora solo estábamos seguros de una cosa
que éramos un solo equipo unido llamado
méxico
después de un duelo reñidísimo
nos colgábamos la medalla de plata un
hecho deportivo histórico para nuestro
país
estábamos felices de alcanzar una de
nuestras muchas metas
cuando comencé en el alto rendimiento
siempre soñé en vivir el sueño más
grande de cualquier deportista ser una
atleta olímpica este sueño se vería
cumplido un 15 de agosto del 2016 junto
a mi compañera de equipo
nuria diosdado seríamos parte de un
selecto y reducido grupo de atletas en
un escenario donde solo están los
mejores
disputar la final olímpica nos llenó de
orgullo porque solo éramos dos país dos
atletas de todo mexico en una final
donde varios quisieran estar
méxico se consolidaba como uno de los
países más fuertes del mundo en todos
los periódicos y noticieros de gran
renombre aparecía karem achach y nuria
diosdado a la final olímpica
pero todo esto suena muy fácil de
platicar diariamente entrenamos durante
8 horas y la paciencia la entrenamos aún
más
había días donde nos sentíamos cansadas
donde nos preguntamos que hacíamos
entrenando tantas horas pudiendo llevar
una vida menos demandante física y
mentalmente
díaz donde no nos queríamos levantar
temprano donde nos queríamos dar por
vencidas
díaz donde no queríamos entrenar en una
alberca fría
pero siempre fue nuestro compromiso con
el equipo y la pasión de cada una
nuestra principal motivación para seguir
adelante
inició el negocio inició el nuevo ciclo
olímpico siendo los juegos
centroamericanos de barranquilla el
evento principal
en la ceremonia de apertura shakira
daría un mega concierto donde sólo
asistirían los países participantes pero
nosotros con lo vivido y aprendido ya
sabíamos lo que teníamos que hacer
enfocarnos a afinar los últimos detalles
con lo que nos fuimos a descansar ya
concentrarnos en lo que seguía y valió
la pena
[Aplausos]
[Música]
valió la pena porque ya damos siete
medallas de oro nos coronamos campeonas
absolutas del evento ganamos todas las
pruebas muy por encima de los demás
países
voy a culminar mi carrera deportiva me
doy cuenta que un equipo está conformado
de gente comprometida apasionada y que
cree en sus sueños
de una líder que motiva e inspira en
tiempos difíciles y que aplaude y
celebra en momentos de gloria pero sobre
todo me doy cuenta que un equipo debe
ser humilde en las victorias y aprender
de las derrotas como decía el gran
michael jordan
el talento gana partidos pero el trabajo
en equipo y la inteligencia ganan
campeonatos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]